TIE-BREAKING VOTE IN THE U.S.
SENATE.
THANKS FOR JULIAN ZILIZER AND
MARGARET TALEV WHO HELPED TALK
US THROUGH.
WITH US IS DEMOCRATIC SENATOR
CHRIS COONS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE KNOW CHUCK SCHUMER VERY PROUD
OF HIS STAFF.
YOU ARE TOO.
WHAT PLEASES YOU THE MOST ABOUT
THE OUTCOME TODAY?
>> THIS IS A HUGE WIN FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS STEP FORWARD
FOR MAKING PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
AFFORDABLE, FOR MAKING HEALTH
CARE SUSTAINABLE, FOR MAKING AN
ENORMOUS DOWN PAYMENT ON
TACKLING CLIMATE CHANGE, AND FOR
REDUCING THE DEFICIT.
LIKE SENATOR SCHUMER, I'D LOVE
TO THANK MY STAFF, THE FOLKS WHO
STAYED HERE THROUGH SO MANY
HOURS.
WE'VE BEEN VOTING FOR, OH, I
THINK 25 OR 26 HOURS STRAIGHT
NOW ON DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
AMENDMENTS.
AS REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
TRIED EVERY WAY THEY COULD TO
KNOCK US OFF OUR COMMITMENT TO
PASS THIS LANDMARK LEGISLATION.
BUT WHAT I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT AS WE'VE BEEN HERE ALL
NIGHT IS THE WAYS THIS WILL HELP
FAMILIES WHO DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT WE'RE HERE WORKING ON THIS,
BUT WHO ARE WONDERING HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PAY FOR INSULIN
IF THEY'RE A DIABETIC, OR FOR
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS FOR
THEIR PARENTS OR THEIR CHILDREN,
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO AFFORD
THEIR HEALTH CARE, HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS, HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HELP DEAL WITH THE
CRISIS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE'VE GOT REAL RELIEF FOR THOSE
FAMILIES ALL OVER OUR COUNTRY IN
THIS BILL.
AND WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
HAD SOME BIG WINS IN RECENT
MONTHS, THE BIPARTISAN VETERANS
HEALTH BILL, THE BIPARTISAN BILL
TO ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH AND GUN
VIOLENCE, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS THE RESULT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY'S AGENDA.
SO AS WE MOVE TOWARDS THE FALL
ELECTIONS, THE SHARP CONTRAST
THAT WAS PROVIDED TODAY ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE IS GOING TO
BE PART OF HOW WE FRAME OUR CASE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHY THEY
MIGHT WANT TO SUPPORT DEMOCRATS
IN THE ELECTIONS THIS FALL.
>> AND AMONG THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAD TO BE ADDRESSED, YOUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR KYRSTEN SINEMA
TOOK ISSUE WITH THE 15%
CORPORATE MINIMUM TAX.
FOR A MOMENT, IT SEEMED LIKE
THAT WAS SIGNIFICANTLY HOLDING
THINGS UP, HOLDING UP, YOU KNOW,
SOME UNANIMITY AMONG YOUR CAUCUS
THERE.
A COMPROMISE WAS MADE.
CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE US A
SUMMATION OF WHAT KIND OF
COMPROMISE THAT WAS MADE?
>> IT'S A COMPLICATED TAX
MATTER, BUT FRANKLY, ONE OF THE
BIG THINGS THAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT ENSURES THAT COMPANIES
EARNING MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE TO PAY A MINIMUM
TAX OF 15%.
WHAT SENATOR SINEMA WAS RACING
WAS A CONCERN IF A HOLDING
COMPANY OWNS TWO DOZEN SMALLER
COMPANIES, DO YOU ROLL ALL OF
THEM UP AND COUNT ALL OF THEIR
REVENUE TOGETHER TO QUALIFY FOR
THAT 15% MINIMUM TAX OR NOT.
IT WAS A VERY LATE CHANGE.
YES, YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT CAUSED SOME REAL
CONSTERNATION.
BUT ULTIMATELY, A DIFFERENT
OFFSET WAS PAID.
THAT WAS ABOUT A $34 BILLION
LAST-MINUTE MOVE IN THIS BILL.
THERE WERE SOME OTHER MOMENTS IN
THE LAST 25 HOURS WHERE A
PARTICULAR PROVISION HUNG IN THE
BALANCE.
BUT WHAT MATTERS HERE TODAY IS
THAT ALL 50 DEMOCRATS AND VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS VOTED TO PUT
THIS BILL FORWARD TO THE HOUSE
AND FROM THERE ON TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
MOMENT FOR DEMOCRATIC UNITY.
FOR RESPONDING TO THE CALLS AND
THE PROTESTS AND THE MARCHES,
FROM PEOPLE YOUNG AND OLD ALL
OVER OUR COUNTRY WHO HAVE BEEN
URGING US TO TAKE ACTION ON THE
CLIMATE, AND FOR THE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF FAMILIES WHO
HAVE WONDERED WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO TO MAKE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
AFFORDABLE, THIS TACKLES THOSE
BIG CHALLENGES, AND DELIVERS A
REAL ANSWER.
>> IS IT DISAPPOINTING TO YOU
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE BIPARTISAN
UNITY ON THIS?
>> I OF COURSE WOULD HAVE FAR
PREFERRED TO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE COULD HAVE
DONE MORE.
THE WAY THE RULES OF THE SENATE
WORK, IF YOU CAN GET 60 VOTES,
YOU CAN DO ALMOST ANYTHING.
AND SO WE COULD HAVE DONE BIGGER
AND BOLDER ACTION ON CLIMATE.
WE COULD HAVE DONE MORE TO
ADDRESS HEALTH CARE COSTS.
BUT I'LL ALSO REMIND YOU, IN
RECENT WEEKS, WE'VE PASSED BIG
LEGISLATION THAT WAS BIPARTISAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
SIGNING INTO LAW NEXT WEEK A
BILL TO INVEST IN BRINGING
SEMICONDUCTOR CHIP MANUFACTURING
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES TO
GROW ADVANCED MANUFACTURING.
AND IN THE LAST 18 MONTHS,
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN AMERICA
HAVE BEEN GROWING AT A GREAT
CLIP.
THIS WILL MAKE THEM GROW EVEN
FASTER AND MAKE US MORE
COMPETITIVE WITH CHINA.
SO WE HAVE DONE SOME THINGS IN A
BIG BIPARTISAN WAY.
THE VETERANS HEALTH BILL, THE
BURN PIT BILL THAT WE JUST
PASSED RECENTLY, THE BILL WHERE
WE'RE INVESTIGATING IN MENTAL
HEALTH AND TACKLING GUN
VIOLENCE.
BUT ON THESE TWO ISSUES THAT
THIS BILL WAS ABOUT TODAY, THE
COSTS OF HEALTH CARE AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, AND MAKING
REAL PROGRESS ON TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE, WE ONLY HAD
DEMOCRATIC VOTES.
IT WAS A CHALLENGE TO HOLD OUR
CAUCUS TOGETHER.
LEADER SCHUMER DESERVES A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR DOING SO.
AND IN THE END, AFTER A FAIR
AMOUNT OF WORK, WE WERE ABLE TO
GET THIS DONE.
AND I SO LOOK FORWARD TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNING THIS
BILL INTO LAW.
>> THIS MEASURE IS ON ITS WAY TO
THE HOUSE.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE MORE
LIKELY TO GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THERE?
>> I THINK IT'S VERY UNLIKELY
THAT WE'LL GET BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE HOUSE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
AS YOU KNOW, I'M SOMEONE WHO
ALWAYS WANTS TO SEE HOW QUESTION
WORK ACROSS THE AISLE.
BUT THIS BILL WAS JUST STRAIGHT
PARTY LINE HERE IN THE SENATE.
I EXPECT IT WILL BE AS WELL IN
THE HOUSE.
AND I THINK SPEAKER PELOSI AND
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WILL
QUICKLY PASS IT.
THEY'LL COME BACK INTO SESSION
SOON, PASS IT AND SEND IT TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK.
>> SO THIS IS BEING CALLED THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
SO HOW SPECIFICALLY WILL THIS
IMPACT INFLATION RIGHT NOW?
>> IT DOES SEVERAL IMPORTANT
THINGS.
IT PAYS DOWN THE DEFICIT BY $300
BILLION.
IT REDUCES THE ENERGY COSTS THAT
THE AVERAGE FAMILY PAYS IN VERY
SPECIFIC AND CONCRETE WAYS.
IT HELPS WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COSTS AND WITH HEALTH CARE COSTS
FOR MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
THERE IS MORE THAN 60 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO ARE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES FOR WHOM
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS ARE A
BIG PART OF THEIR MONTHLY BILLS.
THERE ARE 14 MILLIONS ON THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT EXCHANGES
THAT WILL HELP KEEP THAT HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABLE.
OVERALL, THIS WILL FIND SOME WAY
TO RED